I have two Parent Plus loans for my
daughters and they want to do that pay
for play thing for or whatever that's
called that extends them out and I have
a half of I have $500,000 in 401k and I
also started a new job about five years
ago and I have about
125,000 in that and I was wondering if I
should use that that
125 and pay off in two Parent PLUS Loan
I would okay I you are technically
liable they are not I understand that
they said they would pay them back but
but then they said they weren't well
they're they're going to do that
extended thing well that means they're
never paid back you understand that yes
that's why I the extended plan is 30
years of not even making the principal
payment